Varys: Aegon landed at the mouth of
the Blackwater River and raised a
primitive Aegonfort in the disputed lands
between Harren's and Argilac's kingdom
so that neither could decide whose problem he was.
Adopting the customs of the Seven Kingdoms, Aegon
unfurled his own banner with a red three-headed
dragon breathing fire upon a black field.
Visenya crowned him with a ruby-studded circlet
of Valyrian steel while Rhaenys hailed him as
the first high king the continent had seen since
the Dawn Age. As his lords and the gathered locals
cheered him, Aegon named his loyal friends
to a small council led by Orys Baratheon,
whom he called "my strong right hand." The title
stuck, and he became the first Hand of the King.
But for now, Aegon's kingdom contained only
a rocky island and a handful of fields.
The other kings had large armies, ships, castles,
and thousands of years of rule. But Aegon had
dragons. He had chosen for the words of his
house, "Fire and Blood." Before he was done,
the rivers, fields, and skies would turn red.
Viserys Targaryen: Soon after his coronation,
Aegon returned to the mouth of the Blackwater
River, where he had first set foot on Westeros.
A small town had since sprouted around his
primitive fort. To honor their new master,
the locals dubbed it "King's Landing,"
though it looked more fit for a hedge knight,
with wooden palisades, muddy streets,
and piles of mangled swords carted in
from every corner of the conquest.
But when Aegon made it his court,
wood became stone, black mud was buried beneath a
Red Keep, and the collected swords of Aegon's foes
were blasted by dragon fire and became a seat
fit for the Conqueror and the greatest dynasty
this world has ever known. House Targaryen.
Varys: King's Landing is both a city and a curse.
Aegon the Conqueror was the first king
to land there. His first conquest,
a tiny village at the mouth of the Blackwater
River, where he raised a wooden fort.
When it became clear that Aegon would earn his
title, people flocked to the fort and renamed
it "King's Landing" in his honor. The ploy
succeeded, and Aegon chose King's Landing for
his capital over older and more beautiful
cities like Oldtown and anywhere else.
The currying of royal favor thus became
the foundation of the city, and blood
its bricks. Maegor the Cruel, Aegon's
son, completed the city's famous Red
Keep to hold the trappings of power: the royal
family, the Kingsguard, and the Iron Throne.
To maintain the new castle's secrets, Maegor
murdered all its masons and craftsmen at a feast,
which he catered with the new castle servants,
who soon found all its secrets for himself.
When the Faith Militant challenged his rule,
Maegor razed their Sept of Remembrance to the
ground with them inside at prayer and
erected the Dragonpit on the ashes.
Petyr Baelish: Prince Maegor, a
warrior who was proud and arrogant.
Maegor agreed to marry the High Septon's
niece to unite the Faith and the Crown,
but then secretly wed a second wife in a Valyrian
ceremony artfully combining bigamy and heresy.
When word of it got out, the King was forced to
exile Maegor and choose a septon as his new Hand.
But the damage had been done. The King had trusted
in family, and his brother had set off a rebellion
that would claim his rule and his life.
The High Sparrow:When Aegon's heir wed
his daughter to his son, the Faith
could brook such abomination no longer.
The High Septon led the denunciation of
the Targaryens. And all over Westeros,
the Faith Militant took up their swords
against the dynasty and its supporters.
The Faith Militant set upon and punished
the septon who had performed the ceremony.
A few of the Faith Militant's more militant
members even scaled the walls of the castle
and would have slain the king and his
family, had a knight of the Kingsguard
not intervened. Frightened, the king fled to
Dragonstone, where he soon died of cramps.
And so ascended the king's younger brother, Maegor
the Cruel. His first act was to challenge the
Faith Militant to kill him if they believed his
rule to be ungodly. To the order's eternal credit,
they accepted. Ser Damon Morrigen proposed a
"trial by seven," Ser Damon and six of the Faith
Militant against the king and his six champions.
It was a contest in which the kingdom itself was
at stake, and the accounts and tales are many.
But at the end of it, Maegor alone
lived, proving that the throne was rightfully
his. He mounted the black dragon, Balerion,
and burned down the sept in King's Landing
while the Faith Militant were inside
at morning prayers. The screams of the burning and
dying men were said to echo throughout the city.
Though Maegor had won the trial by seven, he
demanded the complete destruction of the Faith
Militant and the Faith itself, if necessary. He
made war upon the order wherever he found it.
Yet the Faith Militant would not surrender,
raising armies of their own and turning Maegor's
own lords against him. The Father's justice
may not always be swift, but it is certain.
One morning, Maegor was found
dead on the Iron Throne.
No one knows how. Maegor's cruelty died with him.
His successor saw the wisdom of a united crown
and faith, and his Hand reached an accord with the
High Septon. As long as the Iron Throne defended
the Faith, the Faith would put aside its own
swords and its condemnation of the Targaryens.
Viserys Targaryen:The Dance began, as many
dances do, with an old man and a young girl.
The queen had failed to produce a son for
her king, so he anointed his daughter,
the Princess Rhaenyra, as
his heir. But years later,
the king remarried, and his new wife,
Queen Alicent of House Hightower,
gave him a son. Feeble and foolish, the
old king refused to change the succession.
He didn't even see how his court had split
into two rival camps of Blacks and Greens,
after the dresses that the princess and
the queen had worn to some tourney.
One night, a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep and ran to inform
Queen Alicent. Protocol dictated that the bells
would be rung and a raven sent to Dragonstone to
summon the heir, Princess Rhaenyra, for her
coronation. But Alicent had other plans.
None were more surprised to hear of Prince
Aegon's succession than Prince Aegon himself.
At first, the fool rejected the crown, but his
mother pointed out that his sister Rhaenyra
would return such loyalty by taking his
head. As the old king's trueborn son,
he'd always be a threat. Aegon relented.
He was crowned in the Dragonpit,
and his wife and sister Helaena became queen. His
brother Aemond flew off to win over the few great
lords whose support Aegon didn't already
have. The banner of the gold dragon flew
over King's Landing and the Red Keep as Aegon,
Second of His Name, ascended the Iron Throne.
He would not sit it long.
Robert Baratheon: One day King's
Landing looked up and saw two dragons circling
their foul city. Daemon and Rhaenyra had come
for her throne, for the city was defenseless.
Aemond had taken the king's army from the city,
and worse, he'd taken his dragon Vhagar. Seeing
that resistance was hopeless, the small council
surrendered the city, the Queen Mother
Alicent, and the broken Queen Helaena.
But not King Aegon.
Somehow, despite his wounds and delirium,
he had vanished from the city.
And so Queen Rhaenyra climbed the
steps and seated herself of the Iron Throne.
Legend has it that as she left that hall later,
blood trickled down her legs and hands, proving
the Iron Throne had spurned her. Nonsense! It's a
chair made of steel blades. Rhaenyra had wanted it
all her life and had sacrificed two sons for it.
She likely gripped the damn thing too tight.
Shireen Baratheon: When Rhaenyra's last
son wed Aegon's only daughter, the
Dance of Dragons officially ended.
Ash and burned men. All that
was left of the Riverlands.
Two scared children spouting
oaths they didn't understand.
All that was left of the mighty House Targaryen.
Ancient skulls and hatchlings that grew no bigger
than cats. All that was left of the dragons.
The High Sparrow: To steward his monument to
vanity, Baelor summoned the High Septon of
the Faith from his ancient seat in Oldtown
and gifted him with ornate robes
and a crown of crystal and gold.
And like a fool, the High
Septon put on his lord's motley
and danced at his lord's table, and with each
passing year, the High Septons fell ever lower.
How can the flock be kept safe from wolves when
the shepherd sleeps in their den? Baelor himself
appointed a simple-minded stonemason,
believing him the Smith reborn.
And when he died, Baelor replaced him with
an eight-year-old boy whom Baelor had seen
speaking with doves that answered
with the voices of the Seven.
Still, the common people
revere Baelor as the Blessed.
They tell of how he forced a high
lord to wash a beggar's feet,
fasted to tame his unnatural lusts and walked
the Boneway himself to make peace with Dorne.
Many septons and septas even claim that
Baelor rescued his cousin, the Dragonknight,
from a snake pit because no viper would
strike a man so pure and holy. A lie!
Baelor was bitten a dozen times
and was bedridden for half a year,
and yet he didn't die.
Petyr Baelish: When the last dragon died,
it was only a matter of time
before the Targaryens followed.
Varys: By "only," you mean another century?
Baelish: Which they wasted trying to replace
their lost advantage: incinerating
their own palaces to hatch dragon eggs,
drinking wildfire to become dragons, and, let's
not forget the Mad King's favorite, burning men
alive so he could pretend to be a dragon.
Jaime Lannister: Kingslayer. A word every man
and woman in Westeros spits at me, though
many can't name the king I slayed.
I understand. To them, I'm a symbol of everything
they'll never have and a warning that'll never
apply. So they can loathe me from the safety
of their small lives. But when a dog goes mad,
we put it down. Why not a king?
I served at the king's pleasure as
he burned Rickard Stark alive and strangled
his son, inciting the rebellion. I defended
the king's honor against courtiers as his
generals lost battle after battle with Robert.
I kept the king's secrets when his pyromancers
hid caches of wildfire beneath King's Landing.
I gave the king counsel when my
father's army was at the city gate,
and Grand Maester Pycelle lied that my father
had come to save him. Many forget that I also
tried to defend the king from harm.
When the Lannister soldiers poured
through the gates, it fell to me to hold the
Red Keep as the only Kingsguard in the city.
I knew we were lost and sent to Aerys,
asking his leave to make terms.
My man came back with the royal command. "Bring
me your father's head if you are no traitor."
Aerys would have no yielding. His
pyromancer was with him, my messenger said.
I knew what that meant. Aerys Targaryen was alone
in his throne room when I found him, picking at
his scabbed and bleeding hands. The fool was
always cutting himself on the Iron Throne.
"Burn them! Burn them!" he kept muttering.
Aerys had decided to let Robert be king,
after all, over the charred bones
and ashes of King's Landing.
He must have thought his pyromancer was near
enough to obey him, but I'd killed him a few
minutes before in the courtyard.
As I approached the throne,
sanity flashed behind the King's eyes for a
moment, just long enough to read the look in
mine. His eyes grew huge, and the royal mouth
drooped open in shock. He turned and ran.
A single thrust was all it took to end the
greatest dynasty the world had ever seen.
Beneath the empty eyes of the
dead dragons on the walls,
the last dragon king squealed
like a pig and shat himself.
So easy, I thought. A king
should die harder than this.